this movie's a lot of things it is sweet
it's like got a ton of heart but there
should be like a there will be tears
because kids make you crying you're both
parents but it's never like the sad
stuff that makes you cry it's always
like the real happy things where they're
learning something or they're doing that
kind of thing and this movie is so full
of that yeah that's a joke oh yeah yeah
gets your mother laughs and then punches
oh yeah
often times when you have kids on set it
becomes a different experience it
becomes a much different workday did you
find that
yeah but they are you know consummate
professional yeah we have the ability in
the talent that they possess at such a
young age is amazing yeah but yeah you
have schedule and stuff like that you
know uh you know I used to be of the WC
Fields philosophy which don't want to
work with kids right yeah
but are they were absolutely fantastic
yeah sweethearts and you know do you
find that you play a better dad or mom
not when you are a dad or mom I think
having that real-life experience
whatever part you play is always a
benefit for sure yeah um I don't want to
speak of you like you're not in the room
but you've had some fantastically funny
husbands on film I'm from Canada Seth
Rogen is one of them do you rank do you
have a list of your head you know talk
about you don't talk about your other
husband's no it's definitely the most
in-shape I have to know because so we
saw you at the Drake show a couple weeks
ago my office and was like two things we
saw the Drake shot one you are up way
past your bedtime yes and to that
collaboration would be out of this world
love Drake
love Drake he actually we're at my house
we were talked about doing something
with the entourage movie but there's
definitely some stuff in the future
certainly you know him
being in front of the camera and film
and many other things to come from him
would you get in the studio with him
yeah to uh you know supervises animation
it's not supervised I'm 47 I think I
well we'll see if anybody could make it
happen would it be drink if any yeah you
back in front of a my Drake post Malolos
not be there nas jay-z Diddy yeah this
is a [ __ ] allottee a lot of seems like
you really want ready really hold myself
back from asking him it but I did I did
why didn't you she's not bust my chops
every day kept me on my toes
yeah right we're ready we want to say it
half rice thank you so why